what is happening there reject nation
greg and john here today we're gonna
watch from
three c frickin films spider-man no way
home twenties
marvel officially marvel themselves
officially reveals three i count one two
three like three spider-man in this
trailer release also let's get down to
business and see what
chrissy chris chris chris has to say
yeah we're starting to look a little
raggedy but take a little off the top
maybe a nice little tape of fade i
really appreciate that toby
uh and put a shirt on man your nipple
has always tickled my ears
you all right i'm fine okay cool i just
want a big change maybe the best haircut
you've ever given
[Music]
okay
that's a bully mcguire yeah
big change hello spiderman
video my name is chris how many likes is
it going to take for me to rock
a bully mcguire look for an entire
spider-man update
i thought 10k would do it can y'all hit
it but man we're spiderman fans
we just got revealed officially by
marvel themselves
merchants
oh it looks even better we have the
confirmation
of three different suits that'll be part
of this spider-man movie but you know i
had to talk about this because this was
our first look
of spider-man nowhere home funko pops
[Music]
as well as not discussing when we're
getting this damn trailer because it
seems pretty soon so i'm gonna
definitely need your guys opinions down
below there was a lot of talk yesterday
about what we thought of the new suit
that was leaked on lego merchandise now
i really need your thoughts here with
these other two suits because it's kind
of confusing to what is happening in
this film but also don't be forgetting
to hit that like button and smash the
subscribe i
jumped out of bed at 6 00 a.m when this
got shown to make this damn video for me
nice
man welcome to the world it really looks
like this stuff was about to leak online
everywhere i already had a video in mind
for you guys because these funko pops
actually leaked last night before marvel
officially posted it
they actually looked like but there was
a listing of them we got these through
an employee taking a screenshot of
gamestop system and it did say that we
would get three different
suits here an upgraded suit an
integrated suit and a gold
suit looks like marvel knew this was
gonna happen and they were like all
right let's just show them for the first
time
here so i'm gonna start off with these
with the suit that they're probably
gonna start off with in this movie is
the upgraded suit now they call it the
upgraded suit because
this is upgraded from the part that
makes sense
we got set photos but this suit is
slightly tweaked than the way it looked
by the end of the movement far from home
the main key difference here is that on
the belt they took away this like black
strip and instead it's now just mostly
red with smaller black strips but thanks
to that
lego set that we got we know he's going
to be changing it somewhere in the movie
to this suit that we now know is called
the
integrated suit and seems to have some
[Music]
we imagine that oh he just probably took
the one from infinity war
went to stark labs since he still
probably hasn't
tweaked the suit up a bit so it matches
his red and black look but now from this
it looks like it might be dr strange
himself who makes spider-man a brand new
god
that's what i wanted that's what i
wanted rated suit like in the context of
the movie
what does that mean is there a reason
that spider-man needs to wear a suit
that has magical abilities like doctor
strange
it's honestly very controlling and odd
but i'm
kind of open to it whoa my mind was just
like
lost in wonder at that moment for all we
know this could just be a funko pop
right because a lot of times they do
funko pops of things that doesn't
necessarily mean
it's going to be part of the actual
movie or we see it all the time so it
could just be a tribute to the fact that
dr strange is going to be in this movie
and he's going to be working with peter
parker so maybe it's just a reference to
that i don't really know how i feel he's
got another new mentor it's not tony
stark and now he's going to get his
suits
for dr strange tailors the suit to their
own tutelage
and there's an argument to me for the
ones that were designed through star
tech
if this suit is in the deed in the movie
and considering the
the multiverse and all they're going to
be often dealing with for the fact that
he has to
resort to relying on aid from dr strange
it's within the context of the story
that he would get a suit upgrade from dr
strange it's not
the same kind of feeling of look i just
want peter parker to make his own
classic suit considering that this
is going to be like the biggest
live-action craziness spider-man movie
we've ever gotten if this suit is indeed
in the movie
yes all right there's something kind of
cool about like combining the mysticism
of doctor strange powers with the spidey
suit there's something kind of appealing
to me about it
it appeals more to me honestly than
combining it with iron man powers
1000 because it's like oh what does
peter parker yeah need
mysticism yeah and it's like if we're
going to be jumping through the
multiverse like maybe there's a legit
reason for that
it's not just him being overpowered it
feels plot it feels like it's in service
to the story
if this suit is in here since we're
still on the subject
of talking about the brand new suit we
have different looks of it that are part
of hasbro's marvel legends line
and this right here this toy looks way
better than some of the leaked
merchandise
we were getting yeah yeah yeah it looks
great 100 say
i like this better and now it gives me a
little bit of hope to see it in live
action form
i'm going to give you guys a theories
don't spiderman yeah this third suit
i think is going to have a lot of people
wow what the heck does this mean
is we got confirmed that this suit that
we saw from the lego set even though it
was said
inspired by spider-man homecoming it is
still gonna be part of spider-man no way
home and this is gonna be called the
spider-man black
and gold suit that yo as a little
side-piece spider-man suit that he'll
probably temporarily wear
for as long as he did the night monkey
suit and dig it
it really is reminding me of the
spider-man suit that came out in the
spider-man video game where he used to
fight
now this zoo i have to believe peter
makes on his own using stark tech
it doesn't really seem to be anything
related to doctor strange looks almost
wakanda like
yeah actually that's a good call i feel
like this suit
he made personally so that he is able to
fight
jamie foxx's electro in spider-man no
way home we've had this happen in
spider-man
electricity someone like electro that is
a guy with lightning powers and hurts
him every time they come in contact
spider-man would later go on to build
some sort of anti-electricity suit so
that he could stand a chance with going
up against electro i wouldn't be
surprised if that's exactly what this is
right
damn we got two versions of it oh crap
it's definitely in the movie
absolutely wow certain amount of voltage
but i do feel like more people
are gonna like this black and gold suit
than maybe the new red black and gold
suit that we just got
because again looking at the hasbro
marvel legend version of this suit
it is looking icy they even got some red
tips on his hands
i think this is going to be a really
cool looking makes me want to play with
the actual figures the explanation is
nailed down for why spider-man
needs to have all these costume changes
we know the real answer is
merchandise like this and selling it to
weirdos like me
it sounds like just from the speculation
at hand
the suits are all going to be for
specific boss battles
that he's gonna have to use in the movie
and again
you know like a big part of why it's
conflicted to me because the suits all
look bitchin oh look
awesome they all look great there's a
part of the context where i really do
appreciate like oh he'll need a specific
suit to go up against electro
awesome at the same time a big part of
why i think spider-man is so appealing
is that just with the main abilities
that he has
and then the web shooters he usually has
to do a lot of figuring out
using his surroundings in order to take
down the bad guys so if he's relying
primarily on likewise you suit powers
i don't know how i feel about that yeah
spider-man wardrobe change is not as
good if a movie
yeah all about which suit oh god what am
i without the suit not much apparently
yeah
so yeah and and that is something that
does worry me because especially if
these are all
for tom holland as well or maybe they're
not
yes yes that's the one thing i'm hoping
maybe
there will be yeah that other people
will wear these suits and we'll maybe
get to see them all on screen at the
same time together
i don't really care about tom holland
it's mostly about like oh what new suit
does he have
whereas this could be the best of both
worlds true but as a spider-man
traditionalist and watching someone like
tope maguire who wore the same suit for
almost three movies
i would really love for them just to
give tom hall and spider-man one suit
one clean look and that's his signature
look the other piece of merchandise that
marvel officially released that can make
us wonder what the hell is going on
casual doctor strange looks
evening attire gold web obviously we
have some merchandise that we can
it's probably just a toy yeah this is
atlantis
look no with some golden wings on it no
they're biking put it in the movie
it's the blue bunny who doesn't want
spider-man on a motorcycle but all these
other toys spider bites like a trident
mystery web gear a fist made out of gold
web that's kind of cool
as well as the gold suit also having
some gold left
look how cool
what the hell is none of this
merchandise has any hint whatsoever
mysteriously
garfield now this is from disney so it's
the same company
that hit the child grogu from us from
all the merchandise involved with the
mandalorian that first season they
probably have some toby maguire and
andrew garfield merch at least i hope so
and they're being hidden away till the
movie's released and then that stuff can
go public if not man i'm starting to get
really sad
uh spider-man fans happy excited and
deposit is now that marvel themselves
has officially released this
stuff and this is our first look to the
spider-man suit it's a clear sign that a
trailer is
imminent and might even actually now
come out with black widow we were
hearing that they were going to delay
the trailer and post it sometime after
black widow but now with some of these
leaks coming out and marvel now having
my come sooner i think they want this
trailer hitting the internet i would not
be surprised if monday is the day
but since no no it's right after fourth
of july i want a wonderful
day
at the end of the movie i'm thinking
it's still going to be the upgraded
suit that we got in spider-man far from
home i can't imagine the black and gold
suit will be his final suit that's just
such a huge departure
from spidey man and the red and black
suit with gold on it also just does not
feel like traditional spider-man
especially since it has dr strange
abilities attached to it now
they're not gonna make that a permanent
spider-man suit but only time will tell
i'ma throw it off to you guys what do
you think of all this spider-man no way
at home merch which one has got you more
excited the doctor strange one
absolutely
theories to what is actually going on
here editing and everything be sure to
like subscribe
follow me on twitter at 3c film review
as always i'm chris
take care you take care chris you
sexiest son of a
[ __ ] take the best care you [ __ ]
you sexy [ __ ] you smack you around a
few times
call you daddy subscribe to 3c films if
you haven't done so already
guys which one's your favorite leave
your thoughts down below
running the video now and you could
hit the like button if you want and yeah
we should do a pic
baby candy dave getty oh david gandy
if there's anyone at patreon this is
david who i would fan cast as
our doctor strange maybe it would be you
because you're a master
of several arts the marshall the guitar
arts the photography arts the next
logical step is to go into the mystical
arts my dude
you've already lent us sage wisdom over
time and the next level is to go into
the multiverse
if you could bring your unique calming
vibe and wisdom but also with the
magical power to bend all of space
time and reality i think that would
unlock our fullest potential
but in all seriousness dude i hope
you're doing well i love seeing the
pictures that you post
on your uh social media when i get to
check in you take some beautiful
photography lately
which has been inspiring me to get out
and take more pictures in the little in
between moments so i hope you're doing
well
thanks for still being here you're like
one of our longest enduring patrons
love you a lot and we'll see you soon
hopefully